[Music]
so
we have not yet seen i don't think
in the charts bitcoin act
as an inflation hedge right in the same
way that say gold perhaps has
why would that be different this time
around
so this is not a hundred percent it's
possible that i'm wrong about this but
and i say this as someone who owns quite
a bit of
so here's the fundamentals argument for
that right you know as sometimes there's
certain things where the correlations
only
are visible over the very long run you
know like the interest rate graph we
were just talking about yep in this case
you know we haven't seen a long run of
bitcoin but what we have seen a long run
with is gold
and the fundamental thing is
bitcoin's core value proposition is
seizure resistance
that's to say
all stocks
can be seized by hitting a button
as was done with the truckers the
canadian truckers ours was done with the
russian sanctions on 145 million people
billions billions you know hundreds of
billions of dollars i think was just
frozen because those assets existed
on servers that the u.s establishment
had root control over and i say the u.s
establishment that's not exactly the us
government there's a government but
there's also the network of people
who are loyal to the u.s establishment
those are
like certain tech ceos certain newspaper
publishers and so on it's basically
extended it's all the folks who are
basically supporting the current order
if those folks can hit a key and freeze
your assets you don't really own your
assets in a wartime scenario as what
happened with russia just now the assets
aren't theirs now outside the us this
means this has meant that a lot of
countries are re-examining whether they
want to have so much exposure to things
that the us government has has root
access to powell actually had a speech
on the dollar's role and competition
just a few weeks ago where he mentioned
stable coins you can probably find a
better version of this but it's
basically
rapid changes are taking place in the
global monetary system that may affect
the international role of dollar a
central bank digital currencies being
examined to help the dollars
international standing so that is
not some random person
that's the chair of the federal reserve
mentioning a that the dollar's
international standing is being called
into question and b
that cryptocurrencies and stable coins
are related to the preservation of that
standing okay
so when you zoom out signal and noise
that's remarkable relative to where
bitcoin was in 2010 10 years later
the federal reserve chair saying the
dollar's role in international finance
is being re-examined and
cryptocurrencies are part of the
mix of policy responses
yeah that actually shows we are whether
you want to call it winning certainly
affecting and changing things right so
the thing is only those assets that
can't be
frozen or seized are your assets
and
bitcoin has a root system that extends
way outside the united states
to hundreds of millions of people around
the world that value it
and that is not the case for your frozen
assets on a stock exchange for your
valueless dollars your chair that you
can't move across borders and so on and
so forth
there's a shelling point that has been
built up which is probably going to be
bitcoin now why is it not gold well the
thing is there's either physical gold or
you have
you know some certificate which has
counterparty risk right so if it's a
certificate you're back to square one
where it can be seized and and even with
physical gold executive order 6102
showed that
a sufficiently motivated central
government can defeat gold
we have not yet seen
that bitcoin can be so defeated it is in
question
executive order 6102 for those who don't
know is fdr's gold seizure so the very
organized us government at that time was
able to seize the gold and then resell
it on international markets at a markup
it was just this giant tax on all
americans right and
something like that i think is quite
likely to happen because it just takes
all the rhetoric on abolish billionaires
tax these rich guys blah blah blah all
that type of stuff which is
people won't care that someone took on
risk to to invest in bitcoin or hold
bitcoin during the drawdown they won't
care about any of that they will care if
bitcoin is a million dollars and the
dollar is inflated and it's 2027 or 2028
and you need this to fund the us
government
i know that sounds crazy but think about
it like this in 2010
there are people who had seen the arab
spring and they'd seen how important
social media was abroad
if nevertheless having seen that you
projected that by 2020 or 2021 the most
important political issue in the world
would be whether the president could
tweet
for a time period right that literally
one bit flip
on a server in virginia
that you remember the thing we're
talking about with mimesis and what
people fight about 5440 or fight right
this account like the bytes on this
server in virginia okay when i say
virginia is probably amazon's servers
there that twitter is hosted on
the bytes on that server those little
bytes that record what somebody was
saying
that's where the fight is
whether this person can or cannot tweet
is literally a matter like
billions of people around the world
wanted to know whether that bit would
flip this way or that way
okay
that's insane from the perspective of
2010 even knowing that twitter and
facebook had done the arab spring that
they caused social revolutions abroad
that they had connected hundreds of
millions of people
if you had written that the entire
politics of the world would depend on
whether the united states president
could tweet
it would be an extrapolation but that's
what i'm trying to tell you is i do
think that if in the 2010s social media
became what all politics is about
by the end of the 2020s cryptocurrency
becomes what all politics is about you
will not be able to fund your government
without it
you